The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
I didn't quite get a chance to
tell you a few things about
photosystem II last time,
so I am going to go ahead and
finish up with that now before
going onto the Cardiolite story.
Photosystem II shares quite a
lot in common with photosystem
I, but there are a few major
differences.
Photosystem II is the first
link in the chain of
photosynthesis.
It is really where all
photosynthesis starts out on
earth.
And, as such,
it is an extraordinarily
important enzyme,
this photosystem II.
But it is such a large and
complicated enzyme.
And it is also a membrane
enzyme.
As I mentioned last time,
these are difficult to isolate
and purify and crystallize so
that you can study their
structures.
And it was only in the last
couple of years that photosystem
II was actually
crystallographically
characterized,
so there is really a lot of
very recent science that is
relevant to today's presentation
on photosystem II.
As you go through and read
about it, you are going to learn
about the molecules that harvest
the light, and you are going to
learn about where the electron
goes and where the hole goes
when light is absorbed by this
amazing system.
Here is a close up of part of
the system called the reaction
center, for obvious reasons.
This where the reactions take
place that are so integral to
photosynthesis.
Namely we have,
up here at the top,
a manganese-containing cluster,
the structure of which is still
a little bit ill-defined.
As you can imagine,
with a macromolecule of this
size, it is difficult to say
exactly where just each and
every atom is in the structure.
There are still some details of
the structure,
of the manganese cluster,
here, that are not known.
But, nonetheless,
this is where two water
molecules must be brought in and
coordinated and ultimately where
water, which is not a good
reducing agent,
serves as a source of electrons
in this system.
And what happens is this
special pair of chlorophyll
molecules at the heart of the
reaction center absorbs a photon
and goes into an excited state.
And the electron is able to
travel down through a series of
pigment molecules,
and it gets down onto this
plastoquinone A.
And it is able to jump over
onto the plastoquinone B.
And plastoquinone B then can
dissociate from the reaction
center and carry that electron
onto the next link in the chain
in photosynthesis.
And, at the same time,
the hole is stuck back over
here and ends up accepting an
electron by oxidation of a
reduced tyrosine moiety here.
This tyrosine has a phenoxy
residue.
It is connected to the amino
acid polypeptide backbone of
this protein and it is
positioned right here between
the manganese cluster and the
special pair,
so that once the electron is
shuttled away down this redox
cascade pathway,
it is juxtaposed with this
reduced tyrosine,
which is getting its electrons
from the water that is
coordinated to the manganese
complex.
And somehow those two water
molecules, after giving up their
four electrons,
become O two.
And O two gas bubbles out,
and that is the source of the
oxygen that we breathe on this
planet.
So this is, needless to say,
a very important enzyme to
understand.
And I won't have time to go
through an exploration of the
structure today,
but I will lead you into it by
showing you this picture.
And in this picture,
the sort of gray background
that is mapped out here on the
outside represents this
polypeptide chain,
all the amino acids that are
linked together to form the
protein container of photosystem
II.
And you can see that it looks
like a dimeric structure where
you have one reaction center
over here, here is a special
pair located over there.
And then all embedded
throughout this protein you find
many, many cofactors which are
like porphyrins,
but contain magnesium.
And there are these chlorophyll
units.
And then also,
shown in sort of an orange
color here, you see these long
straight molecules.
These are polyenes.
These are carotenoid molecules,
organic molecules that have
strings of double bonds adjacent
to one other so that they can
conduct electricity and conduct
energy.
And this is a really key
feature of this --
-- because the point that is
being made here is that the
photosynthesis does not wait
until a photon actually comes in
and impinges right there on the
special pair.
A photon can come in anywhere
on this big molecule or on these
light harvesting proteins shown
at top and at bottom that come
up and dock next to photosystem
II.
And these light harvesting
proteins are also just chalk
full of light absorbing
chromophores,
chlorophylls,
and carotenoid molecules.
And, if a photon comes in and
excites one of these molecules
over here, the proton has a
mechanism for transmitting the
energy over to the special pair,
so that water can be oxidized
to O two.
It is really quite a tremendous
assembly of different kinds of
molecules to perform function.
And if you go on and take 5.03,
for example,
and then 5.04,
you will learn about the rules
that govern electron transfer
between molecules and also in
proteins.
Let's see.
Finally, on this subject,
I will show you,
here, a view of this reaction
center.
And this just a close-up to
show you that these water
molecules indeed must get in
here.
There is also a calcium ion
present at this active site,
where the water molecules are
being oxidized and converted
into dioxygen.
And here is that tyrosine
residue shown in more detail.
That is very important for the
hopping of the electron from
water to the tyrosine.
And then over here,
after the hole has been
generated through excitation of
the special pair of chlorophyll
molecules.
And so that brings me to the
end of my discussion of
six-metaloenzyme systems that
had quite a bit in common in
terms of the ligands that are
used to bind metals.
We talked about heme last time
and its employment of the
porphyrin ligand in this regard.
But then, you should also
remember that sometimes you see
clusters packed into protein
molecules as cofactors.
We saw last time some Fe four-S
four clusters,
and here, a manganese cluster.
And so inorganic and organic
molecules are all working
together in a beautiful synergy
to enable photosynthesis.
And, having said that,
I would like to now go onto my
final topic, which has to do
with the role that metals can
play in medicine.
Last time was metals in
biology.
Now, we will talk about metals
in medicine.
And there are different ways
that metals can be used in
medicine.
For example,
there are molecules like
cisplatin that are used in
therapeutic methods for treating
cancer.
Alternatively,
metals can be used in a
diagnostic manner.
And that is what I will be
talking about here today.
And so what I did for today was
I went directly to a couple of
the Ph.D.
theses that are in the MIT
digital archive by two students
who worked in the Chemistry
Department here and earned their
Ph.D.
theses doing the chemistry of
technetium.
Now, I like technetium for a
lot of reasons.
One, it is a neighbor element
to molybdenum in the periodic
table.
Number two, it is named after
MIT, so that is wonderful.
Number three,
technetium is unique as an
example, right in the center of
the periodic table,
as a manmade element.
And it has been known for quite
some time, and I am going to
tell you a little bit how
technetium chemistry has evolved
in the MIT Chemistry Department.
And so this first thesis is a
1983 thesis of a fellow by the
name of Mike Abrams,
a very smart graduate student
who was given a very difficult
research problem indeed for his
Ph.D.
thesis.
And that had to do with
preparing compounds directly
from the pertechnetate ion.
And pertechnetate is the ion
TcO four minus.
And, if you look through this,
you will see why Mike Abrams
needed to prepare compounds
directly from the pertechnetate
ion.
And it has to do with the idea
that there is an isotope of
technetium.
An isotope known as
technetium-99M,
M for metastable,
that has a six hour half-life.
And, in that six hour time
window that is the half-life of
technetium-99M,
it is dropping from a nuclear
excited state into a nuclear
ground state.
And I will talk more about that
in a moment.
But as the nuclear excited
state relaxes to the ground
state, this nucleus emits a
single gamma photon at about
kiloelectron volts.
And so that single gamma
photon, high energy photon,
that comes out when this
nucleus decays from 99M to
regular technetium-99,
which has a much longer
half-life on the order of 10^5
years, is what is useful in a
branch of medicine known as
nuclear medicine.
So radiologists will be
interested in this.
And, as you will see,
cardiologists will be
interested in this as well.
And so, because of this,
gamma camera images can be
obtained at high-resolution to
image organs that have taken up
this radioisotope.
Let's point out also,
here, that the chemical form of
technetium obtained from the
generator that creates it is the
pertechnetate ion,
so all radiopharmaceuticals
have to be prepared from TcO
four minus because
that is what you get.
Molybdenum-99 is a product of
nuclear fission.
And so, when people are using
nuclear reactors to make energy,
they are accumulating a lot of
molybdenum-99.
And molybdenum-99 is an
unstable isotope of molybdenum,
and so it is right to the left
of technetium on the periodic
table.
And molybdenum-99 itself
undergoes a beta decay,
in which a neutron turns into a
proton and electron.
And that beta decay converts
molybdenum-99 into this
metastable isotope of
technetium.
So what happens is that every
morning at the hospital,
the molybdenum-99 has been
coated as MoO four onto
an alumina column and is
undergoing its own beta decay.
And when that is done,
you now have pertechnetate on
the column.
And you can elute that in very
dilute solution,
in isotonic saline solution.
You then have a very small
amount of time to do chemistry
with it before you put it in the
body.
Therefore, Mike Abrams,
and I will tell you about the
professors involved in this in a
little bit, was given the
problem of finding a way to take
an extremely dilute solution on
the order of 10^-9 molar
solution in saline and do a
quantitative reaction from
pertechnetate to make something
that would go and localize in an
organ that you want to image to
find out about the patient's
health.
That is a tall order,
but that didn't stop them from
looking into this.
In fact, I included this page
in part, because Mike Abrams has
some nice statements,
here.
He says the reason we carried
out this research was to gain a
better understanding of what
kinds of coordination complexes
can be prepared directly from
TcO four minus with
the hope that such information
might lead to the development of
new radiopharmaceutical agents
and/or to a better understanding
of the agents already in
clinical use.
This thesis was written in
Well, let me not get ahead of
myself here.
And let me just show you here
one of the first technetium
complexes that Mike Abrams was
able to prepare.
And this is a technetium
hexacis thyourea species.
You will see that he has this
pertechnetate and was able to
convert it into molecules that
are octahedral at technetium.
And, in fact,
most of the applications of
technetium in nuclear medicine
do involve octahedral
six-coordinate technetium,
--
-- harkening back to what we
can understand based on the
efforts and achievements of
Alfred Werner.
Here is the octahedron,
pretty soon,
going to go into a patient's
body.
Here he has chosen to use
sulfur donor ligands,
these thiourea ligands in
making this.
And he also made molecules in
which phosphines and phosphites
were able to bind to technetium.
And later, as you will see,
he also did work with
isocyanides.
This is 90 degrees rotated.
Basically, the reason I am
showing you this is that this is
a nuclear magnetic resonance
spectrum of a technetium-99
compound.
Let me just explain that
initially, when doing these
studies, Mike Abrams was working
mostly with technetium-99 that
has the real long half-life so
you can actually make molecules
on a scale sufficient for
isolation and purification.
But then those methods would be
translated to working with the
99M isotope.
And the difference between 99
and 99M, has to do with the spin
of the nucleus.
We have talked about electron
spin.
Well, different nuclei have
themselves the property of spin.
And technetium-99 has a spin
one-half nuclear spin.
And then when it decays from
99M to 99, the 99 isotope has a
spin nine-halves,
actually.
And that is the lower energy
state that gives rise to this
gamma photon emission.
And so, in the nuclear magnetic
resonance spectrum,
observing the phosphorus 31
nuclei that are connected to
this hexakisphosphate of
technetium 1,
you see that there end up being
ten lines.
And that is because of the spin
nine-halves ground state of the
technetium-99 nucleus.
You will see that back in the
`80s, we were looking at
technetium-coupled phosphorus
NMR spectra, as well as,
you saw X-ray crystallography a
moment ago.
This was real nice work.
And let's see what I have here.
After Mike had successfully
synthesized some of these
complexes they started
wondering, well,
can we image organs with these.
The idea was that
radiopharmaceuticals that had
been in use prior to this time
did not really have ligands on
the metal.
It was sort of the case that
they would take the metal in
whatever form they got it off a
generator and just inject it
directly into the patient.
And, in that case,
you don't have an ability to
tune the properties of the metal
to have it localize specifically
at organs that you might want to
image.
And so they thought we are
coordination chemists.
Let's put ligands on there,
and you can use different
ligands.
And then, the molecule will go
to different parts of the body
specifically.
And, when we find the right
ligand, we will be able to do
something useful,
like image the heart.
And so here,
they had an anesthetized dog
that they had injected with a
solution of one of these
technetium complexes.
This was a hexakis isobutyl
isocyanide technetium-99M.
And they were able to show that
this stuff forms quantitatively,
even at the tracer levels that
they are using to 10^-9 molar.
Very dilute solutions.
And so you don't actually get
much radioactivity put into you,
but because of the high energy
nature of the gamma photons that
come out, you can easily image
them with a gamma camera and you
can reconstruct the position
from which that radiation is
originating.
That is what allows you to
image an organ.
And so here is a little
schematic of the ribcage of a
dog.
And you can see that he is
telling us where the liver is.
And then you are supposed to be
able to see kind of a doughnut,
which is the myocardium of the
heart here.
And you see it lighting up real
nice, right here.
So right away,
with one of the first complexes
that they made,
they found that this stuff goes
shortly after injection and
localizes in the heart and gives
you a pretty nice image of the
heart.
And there are different
viewpoints that you can take
when you image the heart using
methods like this,
but this was already pretty
exciting that one of the first
systems they made,
these t-butyl groups on it,
were very nice imaging agents
for a dog.
And then the basis for the
nuclear cardiology application
of this chemistry is that if a
person has had a heart attack or
is at-risk to suffer a heart
attack, has some heart disease,
then what happens is you look
at the heart and it doesn't
become very well-perfused with
blood all the way around,
as it should in a normal
healthy heart.
And so, if there is infarcted
tissue, you see an image like
this, where part of the doughnut
is not lighting up.
And that means that part of the
heart is not getting suffused
with blood.
And so this kind of diagnostic
test is called myocardial
perfusion imaging,
because you are looking at how
the heart is taking up blood in
all of its different parts
because you can look at
different angles of view.
And one also tends to do this
when the subject is at rest
versus when the subject has been
stressed.
So you will hear the term
stress test associated with this
type of image.
And so this is really the first
complex that Mike Abrams made
that they were actually testing
in animals.
Here was an infarcted dog
heart.
You see that there is blood not
getting to this part of the
heart, up here.
And this image was to be
compared with an image made
using a different imaging agent
which was the state of the art
at the time, here,
with just the first one.
And there were so many choices
you could make of what ligand to
put on this metal.
And the first one already works
better than thallium-201 that is
inserted just as an aqueous
solution.
So thallium-201 is also a
popular isotope for applications
in nuclear medicine,
but with technetium,
now, you have the ability to
make coordination compounds
where the ligands are very
tightly bonded to the metal
center.
And then you can attach other
residues to this system by
virtue of how you build the
ligands.
That was really pretty amazing.
And then a few years later,
also in the research group of
Alan Davison,
Professor of Chemistry at MIT,
comes along one James Frederick
Carnegie.
And what he decided to do for
his thesis work was to go ahead
and actually make molecules like
the ones that Mike Abrams made,
but to look at many different
varieties with different
peripheral substituents because
there are certain organic
functional groups that will be
metabolized and chopped up by
enzymes in the body.
These include ester groups,
for example.
You can also attach to these
isocyanide ligands things that
look like little proteins.
And you can see,
then, how those react to being
injected.
And so his goal here was really
to make something practical that
would be useful as a
radiopharmaceutical for imaging
organs.
And his discussion begins by
just talking about the different
groups that he was going to
append to the surface of his
coordination complex.
And then, here is a little
synthesis slide from his thesis.
Mike Abram's thesis,
the first one I showed you,
was actually typed up by hand
on a typewriter.
But Jim Carnegie's thesis was
prepared, he tells me,
I was talking to him last night
about this, using a very
primitive word processor.
One of the first-generation
word processors.
Anyway, that is a little bit
beside the point.
You just don't see as many nice
graphics in these theses as you
do nowadays, but you do see a
lot of beautiful chemistry.
Here is an isocyanide ligand.
Look.
We have talked a lot about
carbon monoxide in this class as
a ligand in its behavior to
transition metals.
And so if you just change the
oxygen of carbon monoxide into a
nitrogen, then you can have a
substituent stuck to it.
Here is an example of an
isocyanide ligand where the
metal is going to attach to the
carbon.
And then, Carnegie decided to
put other groups out here.
Here, he has a carboethoxy
residue.
And the idea was that enzymes
called esterases in the body can
clip off and metabolize the
carboethoxy residue.
And what that will do is it
will affect the way that the
technetium is bio-distributed in
the body.
It will affect the kinetics of
how long the technetium takes to
accumulate in an organ and how
long it takes to then run out of
that organ.
And also, he looked at examples
that have organic amide
functional groups,
all connected to the
isocyanide.
His thesis work was all about
looking at different
isocyanides, six of them on
technetium in the +1 oxidation
state.
It is d^6 low-spin octahedral
diamagnetic systems.
It talks here about the
radioactivity.
It talks a little bit about the
technetium generator issue.
It mentions that he is doing a
lot of this work in
collaboration over at Harvard
Medical School.
They had a lab over there where
they were cleared to use 99M.
The 99 work was done here,
at MIT.
And this was because of the
collaboration that I will tell
you about shortly.
Here is one that I won't bother
to turn over.
But this actually a pretty
important slide.
You will get this pdf file from
our website, but you will see
that he is taking pertechnetate
and saline.
The key feature,
here, is that this synthesis is
quantitative at these very low
concentrations that are what
used for nuclear medicine.
Now, I showed you that Mike
Abrams imaged part of a dog.
And as they progressed toward
doing human studies,
they also imaged the rabbit.
And in these early tests,
you know, you have these
chemistry Ph.D.
students who don't really know
which organ is which in a bunny.
They had to get a diagram like
this, out so they would have a
map, so that when they started
shooting these molecules into
the bunny they would know which
organ they were seeing light up
by the gamma camera.
And this does not hurt the
bunny.
The bunny is anesthetized and
does not know,
so this is a perfectly nice
thing to do.
And this one,
I think the bunny is oriented
this way, here is the liver.
And resting atop the liver on
the diaphragm is the heart of
the bunny right here.
He has a lot of different
images.
These, in the digital thesis
archive, are a little bit fuzzy.
If you want to see better
images, you might want to refer
directly to the thesis.
But you will see that what he
is doing here is he is looking
as a function of time after
injection, just the intensity of
the gamma counts from the liver,
from the kidney.
Notice the heart starts out
real high, and then it clears as
the blood moves on into the
kidney and the liver.
And so you can actually take
these images as a function of
time and see where the
technetium is going in this
living bunny.
And I thought I would mention
that.
But then, I thought I would
also show you this picture.
I have seen this in the real
hard copy thesis,
and it looks much better in
terms of organs lighting up and
so forth.
It is very fuzzy in this image
from Carnegie's Ph.D.
thesis.
This, in fact,
is Professor Alan Davison,
who was himself the first test
subject for his technetium
radiopharmaceutical.
He just couldn't wait to have
this stuff shot into him,
so he could see what his organs
looked like when imaged with a
gamma camera.
That is Professor Davison,
first human test subject on his
own chemistry.
That was pretty remarkable.
Let me tell you just a little
bit more about Alan Davison.
You can go and read about him
at the MIT website,
but this is Professor Davison.
He is a colleague of mine in
inorganic chemistry,
here at MIT.
He became an emeritus faculty
member this past summer,
but his research career spanned
40 years here at MIT.
He came in 1964.
And he did research in a lot of
different areas of inorganic
chemistry, and did not get into
technetium until 1980 because he
struck up a collaboration with
the fellow at Harvard Medical
School, who I will show you
next.
He is a Welshman.
He got his Ph.D.
with the Nobel Laureate
Geoffrey Wilkinson at Imperial
College, London,
after Jeff Wilkinson was denied
tenure by Harvard,
after which he got his Nobel
Prize.
They did not make a very good
choice, there.
But, in any event,
Professor Davison learned and
became one of the top inorganic
and organometallic chemists of
his generation.
And, in fact,
he is now a Fellow of the Royal
Society, which is quite a
special distinction.
I went over there for the
ceremony in London when he was
being inducted into the Royal
Society.
And they pull out the book that
is signed by all the new
inductees into the Royal
Society.
And one of the early signatures
in the book is that of Isaac
Newton.
So he signed the same book as
Isaac Newton.
You have to make sure your hand
does not tremble and blot the
page.
It would be a big problem.
They actually go ahead and
teach them how to sign the book
and practice in advance because
they use a quill pen dipped into
ink, just the way Isaac Newton
did it.
And this coming spring,
Professor Davison is going to
Atlanta, as many of us chemists
are, for the American Chemical
Society meeting there.
But he is going for a special
reason.
He is winning the American
Chemical Society Award for
Creative Invention,
which is a very prestigious
award.
And I believe he is the first
from our department ever to win
the Award for Creative
Invention.
And that can go to a person in
any area of chemistry,
in fact.
That is a really nice thing.
And Professor Davison was a
great mentor of both
undergraduate and graduate
students here at MIT over the
years.
And next let me show you that
it takes not one Welshman,
but two, to make a drug.
And here is the other one,
Alan Jones, a very good
personal friend of Alan Davison.
He and Alan got together in the
early `80s to see if they might
not be able to bring inorganic
chemistry and coordination
chemistry to nuclear medicine in
order to develop a diagnostic
imaging agent.
They got together,
and their research was
extremely successful.
And they have done research in
other areas, too,
together over the years.
And their students go back and
forth between the labs here and
Building 6 at MIT and over at
Harvard Medical School to do the
different kinds of studies that
they do.
It turns out that his
chemistry, making these
six-coordinate complexes of
technetium-1,
has led to the development of
Cardiolite.
This now is called Sestamibi.
That is an abbreviation for
this compound that has six of
these isocyanide ligands on
technetium.
When you see Sestamibi,
you will know what molecule
that is.
It is the one that actually
became commercial and was
approved by the FDA in
after extensive critical trials.
I will show you the structure
in a moment, but it is a
variation on the t-butyl,
where one of the methyl groups
is replaced with a methoxy
group.
It is a methyl-ether species.
And Cardiolite was originally
manufactured and brought into
being by DuPont Merck.
And they sold it later to
Bristol-Meyers Squibb.
And so you will see that
Bristol-Meyers Squibb has a
section devoted to medical
imaging.
And this drug that was the
brainchild of Davison and Jones
is currently the most widely
used diagnostic imaging agent
for looking at myocardial
perfusion.
It is used in heart imaging
tests all around the world,
every day, so it is a very
important molecule contributing
to the health and welfare of
people all over the world.
And what you will see is there
are here descriptions of the
stress tests that people take.
Let's see.
Cardiolite imaging guide.
You have education programs.
Let's just check out the
imaging guide for a moment.
These companies have pretty
good graphics on their websites.
And remember the doughnut I was
showing you, there it is right
here.
There are different ways to
look at the heart using
Cardiolite to see if the blood
is perfusing the heart properly.
That might be the short axis.
You can view the scan images.
This is how a normal healthy
heart will differ when it has
been stressed after exercise or
at rest.
That is why they call these
stress tests.
You are seeing how the blood is
distributed in the heart using
the property of the radionuclide
technetium-99M.
There is one.
That is a different one.
I am not going to spend too
much time on this,
but I am giving you the link to
this website so you can go and
look at how people actually use
clinically technetium Sestamibi
to image the heart.
I want to show you just a few
other things here,
one of which is that,
as you may be aware,
the same molecule can have
different names if it is used
for different purposes.
Cardiolite is one of the names
given to Sestamibi,
but another name given to
Sestamibi, here it is,
is Miraluma.
And Miraluma,
it turns out,
is really quite useful at
detecting breast cancer when
breast lesions are not readily
visible using mammography or
ultrasound.
If you go to this website and
look at the information for
healthcare professionals,
as you all are sitting here,
you will be able to see breast
tumors that are detected very
nicely using Sestamibi that were
missed using ultrasound or
mammography.
And you might like this.
If you try to go into that
information, you're first
confronted with a test.
And you have to pass the test
and know that the risk of breast
cancer increases with age.
If you get that right,
then you can go on and actually
look at the images that are made
using this drug.
Now, I also give you a link
here to the Cardiolite story
that is a nice article written
in the MIT Undergraduate
Research Journal about
Professors Davison and Jones,
their students,
and the creation of this
clinical tool.
You can go there and read that.
And it has some more
information.
And then, finally,
I do give you a link to
Sestamibi.
You will probably be appalled
at the way this website draws
the isocyanide complex of
technetium.
We know very well that that is
a linear bond angle at those
carbon atoms,
not bent like that,
so that is not a very good
representation in terms of
structural fidelity.
But if you want to know which
isocyanide is used in vivo for
imaging organs,
it is this one with the methoxy
group, instead of one of the
methyl groups of the t-butyl
group.
It is very similar to the
original one that Mike Abrams
made first back in 1983 because
they already had t-butyl
isocyanide around from other
things.
It is a really remarkable
story, a fantastic story.
And having told it to you,
I am now going to have to do
something that I very much
regret.
Now you can go on and sample
all the other exciting chemistry
subjects at MIT in your future.
I hope to interact with many of
you again in that context.
And I wish you good luck.
I know that you all will do
fantastic things.
Having said that,
I am going to have to close the
book on this semester.
[APPLAUSE]